salut aujourd'hui on ouvre à castets un
petit peu différent enfin on ouvre on va
essayer d'ouvrir un casse-tête
différence le casse-tête bear kasten
pierre castex est ce qu on dit comme
c'est ce que vous parler allemand je
crois que c'est à dire casiers de bière
c'est comme un casier de bière on voit
les bières qui sont rangés à l'intérieur
je sais que ça s'ouvre comme ça on le
voit là que ça coulisses parce que quand
je les prie jésus doit qui s'est posée
naturellement là et j'ai vu que ça
poussins il a une particularité c'est
cette espèce de truc qui a au dessus
c'est comme un puzzle je veux juste
enlevé comme ça pour pouvoir leur mettre
où il ya six pièces différentes donc je
pense que l'exploration a va être facile
parce que tout va se jouer la
maintenance que j'arrive pas à
comprendre c'est comme s'ils étaient
déjà bien rangé ce n'est pas le fait de
bien le ranger qui va me permettre de
l'ouvrir voilà voilà voilà clairement sa
ses ventes pour la il se passe des
choses là de 20g pareil si la non pas
trop là je vais couper court à une idée
reçue non les casse-têtes c'est pas
rasoir pourquoi cette phrase grâce aux
partenaires du jour bien sûr y avant de
rentrer dans la complexité de ce
casse-tête laissez-moi vous informer que
cette vidéo aujourd'hui est sponsorisé
par philippe saint philippe comme son
oncle philippe non comme comme les
rasoirs philips ah ouais ok non c'est
parce que c'est un casse tête du coup ça
peut être barbant du coup rasoir
barbe rasoir ouais non mais enfin si ça
peut être ça ouais c'est pour ça c'était
ça mon idée tu fais quoi tu fais quoi
quoi tu fais quoi là bas je me rase avec
le one day 360 aboiteaux tapas le thème
là tu es en train de commencer à faire
un partenariat pour toi même du one day
360 sur ma chaîne à moi non si oui non
mais si je me rase avec le wengé 360 et
en plus tu vois là il ya d'hellemmes
innovantes 360 qui s'adapte aux contours
de mon visage oui et dont la durée de
remplacement est en moyenne de quatre
mois pour être tranquille et petit
benare qu'il est le one blake 360 est
équipé de la technologie unique moteur
profond du deuil qui permet de tailler
de faire les contours de raser quelle
que soit la taille de sa barbe de
manière facile confortable et rapide en
vous et pas si tu savais mais le one blé
de 360 et d'un objet connecté comme ça
tu attends tu récupère mon partenariat
là en fait si vous avez envie de changer
de rasoir le lien gouvernants dans la
description pour télécharger l'appli des
liqueurs et gradés votre routine de
rasage comme un pro essayer le nouveau
one day 360 en vous inscrivant au
wembley club dès maintenant est vraiment
une puisque le pack est livrée
directement à votre porte pour recevez
automatiquement des lames de 360 de
remplacement vous définissez la
fréquence tout ça pour un coût mensuel 2
6 euros 99 c'est vrai tu savais déjà
alice est aussi fan c'est vraiment c'est
le bon prix je t'offre merci grâce à toi
même ah ouais
ouais
bon allez et sans se faire mousser
mousse mousse à raser vous l'avez il me
brain déjà d'instinct parce que je le
casier à l'intérieur je crois vraiment
qu'il ya rien à voir parce que ce que ça
ferait comme des pistons ah ouais ça va
être tout haut son poids en faire quoi
ce qu'il va falloir mettre toutes les
pièces et utiliser tous les aimants
peut-être que quand je mets une pièce ça
aimante et qu'il faut qu'après je la
laisse en position quoi
comment je pouvais faire celle ci avec
tous les aimants peut-être orienté vers
le bas
et si ça passe
et oui voilà ça par exemple là ça marche
pas
le fait d'avoir celui-là en centre ça
fait un truc intéressant pour lui ça le
ferait aussi
là je le sens il ya vraiment comme un
look et on l'entend clac clac mais du
coup il faut qu'ils soient de quel côté
je vais j'aimerais bien essayer de faire
des ouvertures comme ça mais alors après
faut trouver comment mettre le reste
c'est le coach qui ce merci là ce serait
lui
ça comme ça serait tellement incroyable
que ça suffit comme ça par hasard la
variante que je viens de faire si vous
regardez bien par rapport au début de la
vidéo et j'ai mis tous les aimants face
en bas à la première mise en place
n'était pas le cas si je pense qu'il ya
plein de manières de le même de toute
manière
ce que si encore ça me donnait des
petits grande ouverture ça me dirait un
cheminot quoi faire
j'ai l'impression que ça à faire avec ça
ça use
ce qu'on trouvait tous les placer en
ouvrant ferment
si je fais ça comme ça
c'est pas quoi je m'attends jonathan
clairement à des miracles
là ils sont bien tenues
ah ouais mais je suis pas d'accord qui
s'est passé
qu'est ce qui s'est passé je comprends
pas comment je les oublie c'est
incroyable s'est passé quoi ah [ __ ]
c'est des pistons ok ok ok je vous fais
voir j'ai réussi à l'ouvrir c'est tout
ce qui compte mais je n'ai pas dit
clairement pas fait dans les règles là
il ya 1 2 3 4 et 5 trucs des espèces de
piston qui peuvent remonter si vous
regardez bien je croyais qu'il ya des
trucs qui se déplaçait avec les manques
on entendait les claques et en fait les
claques qu'on entendait c'était ça c'est
les pistons qui rentre à l'intérieur et
comme je les ai mis là où il est et
aimanté bon bah du coup ça ouverte mais
quant à dire que j'étais sûr de matteo
rien et donc sur le casier comme ça il y
avait cette boite avec tous ces trous
qui était posée et donc pas forcément
quand ça rentre dedans ça bloque et il
n'y a pas de cran d'ailleurs possible
effectivement ceuta bon état pas bon
quoi je me tiens mg/l refaire en
essayant d'avoir bien en réussissant à
l'ouvrir mais en voulant l'ouvrir
regardez ça j'avais pas fait gaffe non
plus or il est très ingénieux il est
super ingénieux quand tu le retourne il
ya ces deux pistons qui rentre saoul
dessous de la boîte dans les deux trous
ce qui fait que si tu leur tourne tout
ce qui est rentable se retrouve bien
face en l'air donc tu pourrais unlock
mais là du coup comme il tombe ça
t'empêche quand même de l'ouvrir
est reparti au départ on va essayer de
l'ouvrir volontairement quoi qu'il
arrive un aimant exactement à cette
position par exemple lui ça c'est
possible en a quatre autres qui traînent
par là
j'en ai pas ici
ici
et ici ça fait 3 4
des 6
2 3 4 et 5 et c'est dans ce sens là
qu'il faut les mettre ok
[Musique]
vous êtes peut-être on n'est pas obligé
de tous les mettre à l'heure quand j'ai
ouvert ils n'étaient pas tous mis en
fait faut juste mettre tous ceux qui
sont bons au bon endroit et là j'en ai 4
sur les 5 qui sont bien mais j'en ai un
autre il se trouve ici vous permet
d'ouvrir clairement ça j'ai compris
c'est bon mais l'idée quand même c'est
d'arriver à tout mettre
si donc j'ai fortement un aimant qui me
certains pour moi ce qui me sert passé
lui on peut pas le positionner je pense
à un endroit où il pouvait servir et non
parce que laïque à cheval il est là il
cache pas lui
non plus ces deux là sont sur la même
ligne c'est de la censure la même ligue
est sur la même ligne que 2 buts à 1
donc du coup lui ne pourra jamais servir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai un deux trois quatre
il me manque lui il le faut à l'appel
[Musique]
c'était galère de trouver donc en fait
il fallait bien servir des six sachant
qu'en fait au final celui ci ne se ne
sert à rien celui celui qui est là là il
sert à rien du tout parce que les les
aimants les pistes on parle aisément
pour lever des petits bistrots en
dessous ils sont positionnés là là là et
là bon on va pas se mentir le premier
coup comme ça à la hache il n'était pas
très légal moi je l'attendais pas il ya
pas deux y est vous avez vu on se plaint
de nouveau projet aussi à la rentrée
baisse assez grasse c'est grâce aux gens
comme le partenaire du jour merci on se
revoit très vite c'est lundi prochain sa
18h notez le dans vos agendas ou marqué
lundi 18h vidéo fabien prenez soin de
vous et à très bientôt ciao